ich war die tage so im world wide web
unterwegs hab so ein kanal entdeckt
namens in tv ich habe mich dann hier auf
dem kanal so ein bisschen umgeschaut
habe so die letzten video titel und
videos halt allgemein so angesehen die
gehen immer so eine minute 50 sekunden
50 sekunden 53 sekunden übels lang auf
jeden fall der kanal hat 70.000
abonnenten und bei den ähnlichen kanälen
habe ich halt direkt gesehen promiflash
berlin tag & nacht und köln 50667
highlights wie ip magazin stars ja wir
alle kennen diese kanäle im aston ist
frisch verliebt von 39 minuten
hochgeladen 324 aufrufe lisa und lena
kommt bald eine zweite single vor einer
stunde mit 800 aufrufen und kate sind
etwa zwillinge im anmarsch war einer
stunde mit 1000 aufrufen da dieser kanal
natürlich nahezu stündlich video
hochlädt es natürlich klar dass die
nicht so ultra krass geklickt werden
dann bin ich allerdings mal hier durch
die bisherig hochgeladenen videos
durchgegangen und habe dann gesehene
update zum buch kommt crafter emotional
wie nie und das hat 10.000 aufrufe warum
gucken sich dass so viele an dann habe
ich halt mal drauf geklickt neu ist zum
buch von crafter der youtuber bereits
zwei bücher rund um das spiel minecraft
auf den markt gebracht zwei bücher
ich habe also bis
ja schon zwei bücher herausgebracht
es ist das ist einfach falsch lieber
david da hast du schlecht recherchiert
ich habe erst ein buch herausgebracht
aber wie schaut das video mal weiter an
doch in hallo mein name ist luca dass
noch in diesem jahr erscheinen soll
dreht sich alles um den 21-jährigen
selbst sagt nicht die folgen jetzt auch
noch bei snap zeit und haben diesen snap
sich abgefilmt und jetzt da hochgeladen
weil sie mehr weiß nature
beziehungsweise bei instagram folgt er
mich arbeitet derzeit täglich mehrere
stunden an meinem neuen buch was wo wir
versuchen dass es am ersten 12 zusammen
mit den neuen klamotten in den luca shop
kommen soll und so weiter und so fort
dort jetzt gar kein werbevideo sein ich
will gar keine werbung für machen da
habe ich wollte nur darauf jetzt
reagieren und die haben halt diesen
ausschnitt aus meinem snapshot auf jeden
fall genommen aber ich würde sagen wir
schauen uns mal weiterhin an eine mutter
geschrieben war
das ist gerade voll krass übrigens ist
der geplante veröffentlichungstermin
defizite dezember diesen jahres doch
was
erster dezember ist geplant
auch dort die freuen uns auf geschichten
rund um harry und mehr
es ist echt so wie promiflash aufgebaut
das video habe ich aber gerade wirklich
nur spontan hier gefunden und wollte
darauf jetzt mal ganz kurz reagieren
worum es aber eigentlich heute gehen
soll
die wahrscheinlichen untertitel
eingeblendet gesehen am 17 10 ist ja
meine pizza herausgekommen und da war
ich an einem supermarkt in köln und habe
mehrere stunden autogramme gegeben
beziehungsweise fotos gemacht und
kostenlos pizza verteilt so dass die
leute die probieren konnten ich habe
extra keinen anderen youtuber eingeladen
und auch allen anderen gesagt wer die
pizza haben wird kann ich euch die ja
gerne schenken und irgendwie
vorbeibringen oder so aber bitte lasst
in diesem moment und so weiter und so
fort
weil ich einfach mit euch quasi zusammen
sein wollte dass ihr die pizza probieren
können uns weiter und so fort
jedoch ist dann trotzdem noch b nach rom
gekommen und hat alles durcheinander
gebracht und es mit security ist dann
alles nicht so richtig gelaufen wie wir
das quasi vorher tagelang geplant hatten
danach die pizza hat nachher mit ins ufo
genommen und in einer mikrowelle gemacht
und hat die verpackung ein wenig
kritisiert und ja das fand ich halt
nicht so cool und habe darauf reagiert
auf jeden fall habe ich in meinem video
auch gesagt ist das mega cool fand dass
die nada war dass ich die geste mega
gefeiert habe und dass ich es gut finde
dass er die pizza auf feiert und so
weiter und so fort aber nur ein bisschen
kritik geäußert an seinem video weil ich
den titel nicht so ganz passend fand und
so weiter und so fort es ist alles cool
wir haben jetzt keinen streit wir boxen
uns nicht wir haben kein beef und wir
haben sogar nicht mal kontakt sodass wir
haben können aber schauen wir doch
einfach mal auf diesem kanal hier vorbei
was ihr hochgeladen wird also wir sehen
hier videos so eine ahnung 11.000 offen
für home media 1900 aufrufe keinen satz
e3 was ist das hat c3 faktor goethe 3
hat hier sogar 55.000 aufruf so stylish
waren die in style award 16.000 justin
timberlake als 2000 gäste lieber sogar
32.000 doch dann habe ich ein video auf
diesem kanal entdeckt was alles
gesprengt hat konkreter packt aus
schwere vorwürfe gegen den aj steht da
halt eigentlich noch 259.000 aufrufe das
ist drei mal so viel wie der kanal
abonnenten hat das video wurde vor zwei
tagen hochgeladen das muss man sich erst
mal geben in zwei tagen habe ich schon
wieder diese ganzen anderen videos
hochgeladen wie viele leute arbeiten
weil es in tv 5000 dieses video hat
innerhalb von zwei tagen drei mal so
viele aufrufe gemacht wie
kanal abonnenten hat das wäre so wie
wenn ich vorgestern ein video
hochgeladen hätte auf meinem kanal und
jetzt hätte es so ungefähr 10 millionen
aufrufe aber ich würde sagen wir schauen
uns das video mal an nicht nicht den
nächsten brief liegt was eigentlich nach
einer geste zwischen zwei fronten
scheint sich jetzt zu einem echten
streit zu entpuppen was die bewertungen
von diesem video sind auch gras also
vorhin als wir uns dieses video
angeguckt haben was über mein buch gegen
das hat irgendwie 99 daumen hoch also
irgendwie 400 likes und neun discs oder
irgendwie so und jetzt haben wir hier
3100 zu 3300 und ich würde sagen ich
gebe auch mal daumen runter weil das
einfach ein blödes video ist aber eine
woche ist es her als luca besser bekannt
als contractor seine eigene pizza in
köln verteilt hat und wer wie wir dabei
war hat mitbekommen dass ich auf youtube
auf
freunde
das problem offenbar wusste niemand von
seinem besuch und das passte luca
scheinbar ganz und gar nicht das macht
ja zumindest in einem neuen video
deutlich nur jetzt kommen wir halt
wirklich dazu was mich persönlich in den
events oder ein bisschen abgeholt hat
sage ich ganz ehrlich so der youtuber in
dem clip über den akku wenn jemand mit
denen gerechnet hat musste sich luca
security-mann um ihn kümmern noch mehr
verärgert haben dürfte luca allerdings
der titel von denen das video youtube pc
für 5 euro gelassen quasi einfach nur
mein video zusammen ich habe mich in
meinem video glaube ich irgendwie 45
minuten am ende zu denen das video
geäußert dieses video fast das ganze auf
zwei minuten zusammen ich weiß nicht
wieso man sich so etwas angucken muss
das ist ganz danach klingt als hat den
lukas pizza satte fünf euro gekostet
aber den zuschauern wird das erst am
ende des videos erklärt da die pizzen
fast überall ausverkauft waren kauft den
us team kurzerhand einem fan die pizza
ab 255 euro meinungen über lukas
reaktion die gehen auseinander
einer schreibt unter anderem kommst
untere arrogant und werden dem video den
er hat nichts böses gemacht andere nimmt
den 21-jährigen den schutz an alle die
seiten luca macht den hkl felix von der
laden runter bin ich völlig gegen deren
meinung er hat hier nur seine meinung
gesagt ja das verstehe ich auch nicht
wieso sehen das alle so an als würde ich
jetzt einen streit oder im beef anfang
ich bin ganz ehrlich natürlich an den
und ich einige differenzen also wir
haben früher viele projekte zusammen
gemacht danach ist der kontakt ihnen wir
auseinander gegangen das habe ich nicht
so ganz gefeiert und so weiter und so
fort aber wir haben das alles irgendwie
eigentlich ad acta mehr oder weniger
gelegt und lasst uns jetzt einfach in
ruhe jeder macht seinen content und ich
meine wir machen auch komplett
unterschiedliche arten von content also
er macht macht er eigentlich noch gaming
ich glaube macht auch gar kein gaming
mehr so richtig er macht halt seine
täglichen blogs seine rennfahrer
geschichte und so weiter und so fort das
gucke ich mir ab und zu an das finde ich
auch cool und ich
ich was mache ich eigentlich für videos
ich mache irgendwie halb unterhaltung
halb halb scheiße da kann man jetzt auch
nicht so super geil miteinander
kooperieren wie ich das beispielsweise
mit max oder seppel oder beispielsweise
einem reh wie machen kann oder so weil
unsere videos sich da halt schon eher so
ein bisschen mehr ähneln allerdings war
mein video wirklich nicht gegen diener
gerichtet sondern einfach nur gegen
einige aussagen die da einfach getroffen
wurden oder dass er das
verpackungsdesign nicht so richtig
verstanden hat dass er dachte dass da
basilikum drin ist obwohl das einfach
nicht möglich war dass ihr die pizza
einer mikrowelle gemacht hat und sie
deswegen labbrig war also habe ich
einfach ein paar aussagen genommen habe
ihm gesagt dass es natürlich klar ist
dass das so nicht passieren kann weil es
einfach so nicht geht es sollte
überhaupt nicht gegen eine person gehen
mein video ich wollte lediglich meine
meinung sagen zu seinem video und das
ist mein gutes recht und ich habe da
einfach darauf reagiert und wie bereits
mehrmals gesagt habe ich ja auch gesagt
dass ich eigentlich cool fand dass er da
war nur hat halt vorschreiben können
dann hätten wir uns hin treffen können
da die pizza gegeben dass wir nicht an
security leute verlieren die eigentlich
für mich zuständig waren aber wir
schauen uns mal den rest vom video an -
müssen mehr diene aber wirklich lassen
in seinem clip hatte sich entschuldigt
und das bitteschön auf bleibt also nur
zu hoffen dass lukas auch reicht ja habe
ich auch in meinem video gesagt dass ich
es mega cool fand dass er da war und
dass ich es auch akzeptieren dass er
quasi sich entschuldigt haben dass ich
das auch neues fand dass er am ende noch
mal gesagt hat sorry dass er vorbei
gekommen ist und dass ein bisschen
durcheinander gebracht hat aber es ging
halt auch um andere aussagen bund also
bauer berichtet über justin bieber wenn
er sagt reis in china um schmeißt aber
nicht über so einen scheiß alter
style stars & stories
könnt ihr mich einfach heraus lassen und
vielleicht irgendwie ja justin bieber
babys beauty palace wenzel in
irgendeinem zehn sterne hotel ist zum
ende dieses videos möchte ich noch mal
einen kommentar vorlesen den ich ganz
passend findet ihr unter dem video und
zwar mal wieder ganz toll aufgebunden
sprach wohl nur weil luca meinte dass es
nicht so ganz neues war von denen aber
trotzdem gesagt hat dass er ihn gar
nicht helfen möchte und erst auch sehr
nett von ihm fand und denen er sich dann
noch mal entschuldigt hat gibt es
natürlich beef genau wie ich genauso
also ich fand von denen paar sachen
uncool habe ich jetzt glaube ich schon
mal was gesagt welche ganzen dinge das
waren andererseits muss ich auch sagen
dass ich in meinem reaction video
eventuell ein bisschen überreagiert habe
also hier vorne sind die beiden videos
eingeblendet mainz hat jetzt sogar fast
eine millionen aufrufe hätte ich auch
nicht gedacht dass es so viele aufrufe
bekommen obwohl das video wirklich 20
minuten lang geht und da drunter halt
direkt youtuber pizza für fünf euro
gekauft von dena fand ich halt titel ein
bisschen miss leading ein paar dinge die
er in dem video gemacht hat waren halt
einfach falsch gemacht so mit der
verpackung und zweitens wolle aber ich
will jetzt keine mehr lange drum rum la
ich will nur sagen es ist kein beef wir
haben keinen streit und wir haben nicht
mal kontakt so dass wir überhaupt streit
haben könnten also es geht einfach in
mich und es ist alles cool und in sinti
und stars und hobby flash und wie sie
nicht alle heißen
ich finde es cool wenn ihr wirklich
kurze clips hochladen zu relevanten
themen aber zu so was das wirkt so ein
bisschen aus den fingern gesaugt ich
wollte halt unbedingt auf felix video
reagieren weil ich darunter sehr viele
kommentare gelesen habe von wegen bei
fünf euro vor die kacke oder bor wie
labbrig ist denn die pizza bei euch dann
am ende geworden oder body so verpackung
macht er gar keinen sinn habe ich mich
einfach angegriffen gefühlt weil wir uns
dabei allen sachen wirklich gedanken
gemacht haben und dass so ein bisschen
dort mit füßen getreten wurde sage jetzt
mal ohne dass jetzt wieder einer das so
einen brief interpretiert meiner meinung
nach ist das mein gutes recht dass ich
darauf reagieren da vielleicht habe ich
ein bisschen überreagiert an manchen
stellen dann tut es mir leid an der
stelle aber ich möchte keinen streit und
ich möchte auch nicht mit irgendwelchen
star beiträgen gedeckt werden also bitte
danke tschüss glas wasser das war's
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job schenken ihr findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wendischen
abonnenten zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]